Speaker 1: Hey, this is a wild, wild story.
Yesterday, Trump crony who was convicted and then
pardoned, actually, by Donald Trump. Roger Stone
was served lawsuit papers while on.
The air, this is a really, really wild
situation, Roger Stone served lawsuit
papers during a live radio interview.
Notorious Republican dirty trickster and Trump
adviser Stone had a radio interview interrupted
by a process server, audio was posted to Twitter
by former federal prosecutor Ron Philip Koski.
We're going to take a look at that video. While
Roger Stone was live on air this morning with
real talk, 933 St. Louis doing an interview about
2024. He got served a process server served by a
process server with the January 6th lawsuit.
This is really something else. Take a listen.
Speaker 3: Ask you, you know, you've
said before that Trump should run again,
but I think lately you said it's imperative he
run in 2024. Is that right? Well, there's been
absolution, in my view point. I really you know,
in politics, three and a half years is a lifetime
at least.
Speaker 1: And
so now it starts to get he starts to get
distracted. You can tell something's going on.
Speaker 3: And I really did not know if. Hold
on a second. I have a process server at my front
door about to serve me in the latest lawsuit. I am
going to take my life, your radio and your radio,
these folks. Well, good morning, sir. How are
you? You know what I have? Yes, of course. I'll
be happy to accept your promotion to be with the.
Oh, yes. A civil court in
the District of Columbia.
Yes. It's still a fraud. Does it matter? Thank
you, sir. Appreciate it. All right. I've just
been served in general who lives right here
on your radio. While tomorrow's news today,
tomorrow big. This is a big, big stack of
papers, which is good because we're out of
toilet paper today.
Speaker 1: So it's
quite a funny guy, huh?
Speaker 3: Oh, my gosh. Oh, my Roger.
Oh, my God. You know, it's like I
said, it's warfare. It's harassment.
Speaker 1: Oh, yeah. So this is a civil suit.
Maybe it'll get some money out of Roger Stone.
But I have to tell you, this guy has really shown
over the last few years he is a slippery guy and
he ends up somehow wiggling out of every problem.
Remember when I interviewed him a few years ago,
he said, I'm never going to be charged. No
way. Of course, he was ultimately charged. He
was convicted and subsequently pardoned by Donald
Trump. I mean, the guy really is like a parasite
on the political system and it's a civil
suit. Maybe this will lead to some financial
consequences for him. But quite frankly, I'm
feeling pretty done imagining that Roger Stone
is ever really going to face consequences. And
there's sort of a two there's two stories there.
One is how have so many morally
bankrupt and despicable people,
how have they become so powerful and prominent
insiders to the American political system? That's
one question. And there are many answers
to that, including that the system itself
attracts these folks by its very nature. It is a
systemic, structural answer to that question. But
then the second part of it is by that very same
nature of attracting those people and putting
them into positions of power, many of them end
up unscathed on the basis of the things that
they do in carrying out their henchmen activities
within that very same political system. So
very interesting to hear. No doubt Roger Stone
served while on the air. But I am sort of beyond
imagining that this guy is going to really
face serious consequences. Hey, this is a very
strange voicemail that I received. You guys
remember from last week we had this coughing woman
at a Nebraska grocery store who was basically
weaponized and coughing. And she was ultimately
after being caught on a viral video coughing on
shoppers at a Nebraska grocery store. She was
fired by her then employer, SAP, the software
company, the business process software company